[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад на наші уроки англійської мови.
Ми продовжили говорити про роботу,
і сьогодні я хочу, щоб ви швидко
зазирнули у майбутнє, давайте подивимося
, які професії будуть
зникнуть у наступні 10 чи 15 років, і
які з них стануть популярнішими та
фактично більш поширеними, тепер ви можете побачити
цю таблицю, і зараз вона вся порожня, тому
я хотів би, щоб ви зараз заповнили цю таблицю
своїми ідеями та  У першому
стовпчику ви повинні мати професії, що вмирають,
визнайте, що професії, які можуть
зникнути, нам не знадобляться навіть у
найближчому майбутньому, а друга
колонка – це роботи, які стануть
популярнішими та більш поширеними через 10 чи 15
років, тому знайдіть час,  хвилину або близько того і
напишіть, будь ласка, свої прогнози, тоді
ми послухаємо, ми послухаємо
лекцію, а потім у вас, можливо, будуть
інші ідеї, і, можливо, ви зміните
свою думку, добре, тому я даю вам
хвилину подумати про  вмираючі професії та
головне майбутнє  вакансії та заповнюйте таблицю
добре, тому я сподіваюся, що у вас особисто є ваші ідеї.
Я думаю, що професії, що вмирають,
це ті, які потребують свого
роду доставки, або, можливо, якісь роботи
замінять нас на фермах, тому я думаю,
що, ймовірно, нам не знадобиться  водіїв
у майбутньому, тому що під час подорожі
Європою я бачив навіть великі кораблі на
річках або навіть в океані без
людей, і їх
керували люди, які сиділи в офісах
і використовували ті джойстики, які ми використовуємо для
відеоігор і для  найкращі майбутні робочі місця
Я думаю, що нам все ще знадобляться лікарі,
і ми все ще будемо потребувати, я сподіваюся, що так, вчителі,
і я все ще сподіваюся, що нам знадобляться ті
люди, які піклуються про нас, як
косметологи і, можливо,
перукарі і так далі, то давайте  слухайте і добре,
тож ви почуєте лекцію
про майбутнє ринку праці Ринок праці
- це ринок усіх робочих місць, які у нас
є, тому подумайте про всі вакансії, а
вони на ринку праці праця означає роботу
означає роботу, тоді ви  мати т  o обведіть
відповіді, які є правильними відповідно
до запису, не відповідно до того, що ви
знаєте, а відповідно до лекції
і подивіться тут обидві відповіді
можуть бути правильними, тому, можливо, це
буде просто а або B або це може бути обидва давайте
візьмемо  подивіться на
перше запитання, тож перше запитання, яке
доповідач описує перехідний
перехід, означає перехід від однієї точки
до іншої, тож опишіть перехід
від економіки, заснованої на сільському господарстві, до
індустріальної економіки, заснованої на сільському господарстві, це
означає, що країна заробляє гроші
за допомогою  допомога фермерів так багато
фермерів багато сільського господарства вирощування
рослин вирощування великої рогатої худоби і це приносить
гроші в економіку країни та
індустріальну економіку означає, що
країна багата заводами, заводами
і виробляє машини від
індустріальної економіки до сучасної
інформаційної економіки
добре  індустріальна економіка, тобто про
заводи і фабрики, машини, а
інформаційна економіка означає економіку,
де ма  ss продукт - це інформація - це
коли ми продаємо і купуємо переважно
інформацію добре друге питання
технологія змусила людей стати
надлишковими, щоб стати надлишковими, значить
втратити роботу, щоб бути звільненим, не мати роботи,
так змусити людей стати надлишковими
означає зробити людей жити  з їхньої роботи,
а ми в промисловості, чи в офісних роботах
чи офісних роботах, добре номер три
модельєри актори та винахідники винахідник
винахідник — це людина, яка винаходить, яка
придумує нові ідеї, і
вони можуть бути науковцями або підприємцями,
які придумують  з новими ідеями, і вони
винаходять те, що нам дійсно потрібно для нашого
життя,
тому модельєри, актори та
винахідники, можливо, мають творчий елемент у
своїй роботі, і їх також можна
замінити машинами, а чи
можна замінити ці роботи машинами, які
ви повинні слухати та відповідати відповідно до
до слухання, але не до вашого
минулого, добре, номер чотири перукарі
згадуються як приклад щодо
творчої роботи або роботи, яка потребує
інтерпе  особисті навички чи пам’ятаєте ви
урок, коли ми говорили про м’які
навички, навички, необхідні для
спілкування з іншими людьми, тому
їх також називають міжособистісними навичками
добре, і останнє запитання в майбутньому
, можливо, доведеться адаптуватися до мінливих
обставин, щоб просто бути  гнучкий і
вивчати нову роботу кілька разів протягом життя,
можливо, згідно з лекцією знову,
можливо, вам доведеться міняти роботу
кілька разів заживо це дуже незвично
для наших батьків і для наших бабусь і дідусів,
тому що вони звикли працювати на одній
посаді і мати одну роботу  одна кар'єра
протягом усього їхнього життя, але в нашому
світі, що швидко змінюється, нам потрібно дуже швидко адаптуватися,
і нам потрібно бути гнучкими,
можливо, знову ж таки відповідно до лекції
відповідно до прослуховування вам
доведеться відзначити обидві відповіді або лише одну добре,
хлопці, я сподіваюся, що  всі
запитання зрозумілі, і ви готові до
прослуховування добре слухайте це дуже уважно,
дякую, гм, я сьогодні тут, щоб допомогти вам
зробити  правильні рішення щодо вашої
майбутньої кар’єри ринок праці
постійно змінюється, можливо, ваші прадідусі й
прадідусі працювали в сільському господарстві за
дні до того, як механізоване землеробство очистило
їх від землі, ймовірно, ваші бабуся і дідусь
працювали в промисловості вугільні шахти,
суднобудівні заводи та фабрики з
тисячами ручних робітників  керувати
складальними лініями та фактично виготовляти
речі. Ваші батьки, швидше за все,
будуть працювати в офісах з кондиціонерами,
факсами, комп’ютерами та плоскими
екранами, створюючи електронні таблиці, надсилаючи
електронні листи та бравши участь у
відеоконференціях у наш комп’ютерний вік
фабрики безлюдні, як поля
у країні роботи та машини
контролюють конвеєри, а
армію синіх комірців
замінила купка техніків у білих халатах, які
натискають кнопки та перевіряють монітори,
але сьогоднішня інформаційна економіка не
застрахована від змін, машини замінюють
білих комірців  так само, як трактори
замінили фермерів, а роботи замінили  ced
працівники фабрики
скільки банківських касирів втратили
роботу через автомати,
коли ви востаннє зв'язувалися безпосередньо
з телефонним оператором,
скільки часу турагент проживе
на головній вулиці тепер, коли через Інтернет
так легко бронювати онлайн
бухгалтери секретарі
менеджери з персоналу радники з обслуговування клієнтів
усілякі адміністративні працівники
замінюються машинами, і це
лише початок комп’ютери, які нам потрібні
сьогодні, завтра ми можемо не знадобитися, тому в
світі, де роботодавці використовують технології для
підвищення ефективності та скорочення
витрат  Ваша кар'єра процвітає,
які роботи є безпечними, хороша
новина полягає в тому, що програмні програми та
машини не можуть виконувати будь-яку роботу, наприклад,
роботи, які потребують великої творчості
письменники модні дизайнери музиканти
актори винахідники дизайнери ігор та
люди, які працюють у сфері маркетингу чи досліджень
і розробок, це правда  що не
всі мають масштаби чи винахідливість, щоб
працювати в цих сферах, але  це не
означає, що ви приречені на безробіття, якщо у
вас немає творчого
темпераменту в майбутньому,
для вас будуть роботи, які потребують
емоційних навичок, де люди працюють так, щоб
бути людьми, які створить
сьогоднішня інформаційна економіка  шлях до
економіки завтрашнього дня, машини не дбають,
машини не можуть піклуватися, тому вони не можуть
замінити людей у професіях, де турбота –
е те, що має значення в службі охорони здоров’я, на
риклад, лікарі та медсестри завжди зн
йдуть роботу, оскільки вони володіють на
ичками міжособистісного спілкування  необхідні в економіці догляду,
вони повинні прислухатися, вони повинні
зробити так, щоб їхні пацієнти відчували себе добре, вони
повинні піклуватися, вони повинні бути людьми або працювати в
особистих послугах перукарі,
наприклад, перукарі не просто стрижуть волосся,
вони також слухають своїх клієнтів, які пропонують
поради та  обговорюйте останні новини та
пліткуйте за чашкою приємного чаю я не
уявляю, щоб мені підстригли волосся на машині
чи є багато інших професій
вчителі косметологи ден  спеціалісти
психологи садівники фітнес-тренери
тощо, чиї навички виходять за межі
здібностей машин і які пропонують
вигідну кар’єру в майбутньому.
точила для олівців,
так що добре, хлопці, ви прослухали це
вперше, а тепер будьте готові з відповідями
і слухайте знову, я сьогодні тут, щоб допомогти
вам прийняти правильні рішення щодо
майбутньої кар’єри ринок праці
постійно змінює ваших прабабусь і дідусів
можливо, працювали в сільському господарстві за
дні до того, як механізоване сільське господарство очистило
їх від землі, твої бабуся та дідусь,
ймовірно, працювали на вугільних шахтах,
верфях на металургійних заводах і фабриках з
тисячами ручних робітників, які керували
складальними лініями і фактично виготовляли
речі, на яких, швидше за все,
будуть працювати ваші батьки  офіси з кондиціонерами,
факсами та комп’ютерами та плоскими
екранами, створюючи електронні таблиці, що надсилають
ел  пошти та беручи участь у
відеоконференціях у цю комп’ютерну епоху
фабрики так само безлюдні, як поля
в країні, роботи й машини
контролюють конвеєри, а
армію синіх комірців
замінила купка техніків у білих
халатах  кнопки та монітори перевірки,
але сьогоднішня інформаційна економіка не
застрахована від змін машини замінюють
робочих так само, як трактори
замінили фермерів, а роботи замінили
робітників фабрик,
скільки банківських касирів втратили
роботу через автомати,
коли ви востаннє
пройшли  телефонному оператору-людині,
як довго турагент проживе
на головній вулиці тепер
, коли Інтернет зробив так легко
замовляти онлайн бухгалтери секретарі
менеджери по персоналу
консультанти з обслуговування клієнтів усілякі адміністративні
працівники замінюються машинами, і
це лише початок  Комп’ютери,
які нам потрібні сьогодні, можуть не знадобитися нам
завтра, тому в світі, коли  переробники
використовують технології, щоб підвищити ефективність
і скоротити витрати, які ваші кар'єрні
перспективи, які вакансії є безпечними,
хороша новина полягає в тому, що програмні програми
та машини не можуть виконувати будь-яку роботу,
наприклад роботу, яка вимагає великої
творчості письменники модні дизайнери
музиканти актори винахідники ігри
дизайнери та люди, які працюють у сфері
маркетингу чи досліджень і розробок
, правда, що не всі мають
масштаби чи винахідливість, щоб працювати в цих
сферах, але це не означає, що ви
приречені на безробіття, якщо ви не
наділені творчим темпераментом
у майбутньому  для вас будуть
робочі місця, які вимагають емоційних навичок,
де люди працюють, щоб бути людьми,
інформаційна економіка сьогодні
зробить місце для економіки
завтрашнього дня, машинам байдуже, машинам
байдуже, тому вони не можуть замінити людей
у професіях, де
в медичній службі важлива допомога, наприклад,
лікарі та медсестри завжди знайдуть роботу,
тому що вони мають інтерпе  особисті
навички, необхідні в економіці догляду, вони
повинні прислухатися, вони повинні зробити так, щоб їхні
пацієнти відчували себе добре, вони повинні піклуватися,
вони повинні бути людьми або працювати в
перукарнях з особистих послуг,
наприклад, перукарі не просто стрижуть волосся,
вони також прислухаються до пропозицій своїх клієнтів
поради
та обговорюйте останні новини та плітки
за чашкою приємного чаю
Я не можу уявити, щоб мені підстригти волосся на машині
, чи є ще багато
професій вчителі косметологи
стоматологи психологи садівники фітнес-
тренери тощо, чиї навички не під
силу машинам  і які пропонують
корисну кар’єру в майбутньому,
гнучкість буде життєво важливою, а навчання протягом усього
життя – реальність, вам може знадобитися
перекваліфікуватися на нові роботи протягом усього
робочого життя, тому не викидайте
точилки для олівців.
Добре, хлопці,
я сподіваюся, що ви прослухали лекцію  що вам сподобалося, і насправді
ця лекція нам багато про що розповідає і добре
пояснює картину світу, який ми
маємо сьогодні, то що ви думаєте
аб  перше запитання, тому доповідач
описує перехід лише від однієї
економіки до іншої або від усіх
економістів, які ми мали до
сьогодні правильні, обидві відповіді
правильні a та B, доповідач говорить про
економіку, засновану на сільському господарстві, а потім
її  перехід до індустріальної економіки,
а потім від індустріальної економіки до
інформаційної економіки,
крім того, вони говорять про новітню
економіку, економіку, де люди піклуються,
і друге питання, технологія
змусила людей стати зайвими, де
і знову обидві відповіді є правильними,
машини замінили людей на заводах і
фабрики і навіть ферми, і знову
машини замінили людей в офісній роботі,
тому що ці крихітні речі, розумні
форми, які ще менші, замінили
такі роботи, як, наприклад, помічники,
тому що у нас хороший цифровий помічник
Siri або Ally Excel або хтось інший,
а насправді хтось  інакше ви бачите, що
це штучний інтелект, і ми надаємо
йому людські риси, а я подзвонив Алексу  а
вона, і насправді, можливо, зараз це правда,
тоді приходять модельєри, актори та
винахідники, і те, що про
них правда, полягає в тому, що вони мають
творчий елемент у своїй роботі, і
оскільки вони мають творчий елемент у
своїй роботі, вони поки що не можуть бути
замінені машинами, але ніхто не знає,
що може статися з
розвитком штучного інтелекту, тоді ми підходимо
до економіки догляду, де люди піклуються
один про одного, а перукарі
згадуються, оскільки приклад над
правильною відповіддю - це робота, яка вимагає
навичок міжособистісного спілкування, коли ви приходите
до перукарні або коли ви приходите до
косметолога, щоб зробити свої нігті, ви
не сидите спокійно, ви починаєте балакати, ви
розмовляєте, а іноді люди приходять зі
своїми проблемами або зі своїми щасливими речами
і хочуть обговорити це зі своїм
косметологом або перукарем і  ці
люди повинні мати дуже сильні
навички міжособистісного спілкування, їм потрібно слухати,
їм потрібно піклуватися добре, я останнє
питання в майбутньому це  може
знадобитися адаптуватися до мінливих
обставин або вивчити нову роботу кілька
разів протягом вашого життя обидві відповіді
правильні вам потрібно адаптуватися вам потрібно бути
гнучким і, можливо, вам доведеться
змінити свою кар’єру чи роботу добре, хлопці, це
була досить цікава лекція
і  особисто мені це дуже подобається,
тому що це дає мені чітке
бачення теперішнього світу добре, давайте рухатися далі, тож
ось список, який я склав після
прослуховування, так що, на мою думку, це
касіри банківські бухгалтери друкарки касири
працівники з нарахування заробітної плати секретарі від дверей до дверей
продавці та фабричні працівники, які
займаються професійною діяльністю, тому що ці
роботи не вимагають навичок міжособистісного спілкування,
вони не є креативними, і їх можна
легко замінити машинами,
добре, і кращі майбутні роботи, інженери програмного забезпечення
так, це гостра проблема,
тому що всі ми використовуємо різні програми та
ті  додатки мають бути написані цими
інженерами та адміністраторами баз даних.
Дані означають, що кількість інформації
зростає, і ми  потрібні ті
люди, які будуть займатися цим і які
працюватимуть з цим, тоді приходить робота в галузі охорони здоров'я,
я навіть не повинен коментувати, що
з цією пандемією робота в галузі охорони здоров'я є
найвищою вакансією у всьому
світі, тоді вони медсестри особистого догляду
ATS і так  від сервісних техніків зараз
дійсно залежали від машин, і нам
потрібні ті люди, які можуть подбати про
машини, які знають, як їх ремонтувати та
як змусити їх працювати швидше та краще
аналітик із інформаційної безпеки пише, що ми
розміщуємо всю нашу інформацію в
Інтернеті, яка нам потрібна, щоб  будьте безпечними,
це мій список, можливо, ваш список
майже такий самий або він може
відрізнятися, але пам’ятайте,
що ми переходимо в
економіку тут від інформаційної
економіки добре, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що вам
сподобалося це прослуховування, і вам  ви готові
до деяких вправ, цього разу
ми не матимемо граматичних вправ, у нас будуть
вправи на словниковий запас і різновид граматики,
тому це називається використанням англійської мови, коли
вам потрібно  використовуй мову добре
подивіться на першу, ви повинні
вибрати правильні відповіді, давайте прочитаємо
речення та виберемо правильну відповідь,
тому перша викладацька робота - це робота
, яка вимагає великого терпіння,
я говорю тут не  про людину, яку я
говорю про те, що викладає, тож я
повинен вибрати, що викладання всього
речення - це робота, яка
вимагає багато терпіння. Друге речення моя
робота в порядку, за винятком свят,
які або занадто короткі  здається,
що можливі обидва слова, але тут у
вас є кома, і якщо у вас є кома
в такому речення, то ви не можете використовувати те,
що використовується в закриванні без коми,
добре, тому ще раз усе речення моя
робота в порядку, крім  свята,
які занадто короткі номер три,
жінці, яка або яка брала мене на співбесіду
на роботу,
схоже, подобаються мої відповіді, коли ми говоримо
про людей, нам потрібно використовувати займенник who
і це має бути таким, як жінка, яка
брала мене на співбесіду на роботу, здавалося,
люблю  мої відповіді злочин наступний
Данія та Норвегія – романтичні
країни
, де звичайні працівники добре отримують
високі зарплати. Данія та Норвегія
– це країни, і коли ми думаємо
про територію, ми думаємо про те, де
і правильною відповіддю буде Данія
та Норвегія.  країни, де
звичайні працівники отримують високі зарплати,
наступний номер п'ять людина нічого
або якій я надіслав своє резюме зараз у відпустці
, я не можу використовувати це з
людьми, це означає, що тут мені
нічого не потрібно, і все речення буде
Будьте таким, як людина, яку я надіслав своє резюме, зараз
у відпустці, якщо наступного
Нік був звільнений, не отримавши
чіткої причини, яка чи що його дуже засмутило,
що таке питання, а
це не промова, і ми можемо»  не
використовуйте його в середині просто так або
щось подібне, тому правильною
відповіддю є те, який Нік був звільнений, не
отримавши чіткої причини, яка
його дуже засмутила, і останнє речення
важливо  робити щось або
нічого, що вам подобається в житті, ви не можете
використовувати те, що вам подобається на початку, якщо це не
повідомлена мова, якщо це не непряме
питання, тому ви не повинні використовувати нічого тут
, важливо робити те, що вам подобається
в житті насправді  це моя порада для вас,
або це справді важливо робити те, що
вам подобається в житті, добре, давайте йти далі, тепер у
вас є відділи, і ви повинні
сказати їх обов'язки, давайте
переглянемо відділи, ви перейдете,
їхні облікові записи, маркетинговий персонал або
людські ресурси, можливо  Ви чули H про наші
дослідження та розробки служби підтримки клієнтів,
зв’язки з громадськістю, ви чули,
що це PR, і ви повинні зв’язати
їх із їхніми обов’язками, я
сподіваюся, що ви ознайомилися з їхніми
обов’язками.
що вони ведуть книги,
другий маркетинг, а у відділі маркетингу
планують рекламні
кампанії, хлопці дивляться, а не компанії,
а  t рекламувати інше слово, потім приходить
персонал або кадри, і вони
готують контракти для співробітників, вони
працюють зі співробітниками, добре,
наступні дослідження та розробки, тому вони
розробляють нові продукти, це люди,
які приходять з новими ідеями,
а потім приходить обслуговування клієнтів, вони
розглядаємо скарги клієнтів, ми всі
телефонуємо в службу підтримки, коли у нас виникають
проблеми з товарами, які ми купили, чи
з нашими комп’ютерами чи чимось подібним
, потім приходить продаж, вони організовують
продаж продукту дуже важливий
відділ, вони насправді заробляють гроші для
компанії  і останнє - це
зв'язки з громадськістю, і зв'язки з
громадськістю відповідають за контакти із
ЗМІ, тому вони показують зображення
компанії ЗМІ, і вони спілкуються
зі ЗМІ, добре,
хлопці, так що це були відділи та
їх відповідальність, а останній
- це ваші  домашнє завдання, хлопці, ви повинні подумати
про свою майбутню кар’єру, чи буде вона
конкурентоспроможною, і я хотів би, щоб
ви зазначили свої ідеї, які ви хочете  Мені вони потрібні на
наступних уроках, це був дуже, я
сподіваюся,
цікавий урок, який дає вам дуже
чітке бачення сьогоднішньої економіки та
сучасної картини світу, подумайте про
свою кар’єру, подумайте, чи є вона конкурентоспроможною
чи ні,
вивчайте англійську мову та  весело
до побачення
[музика]
ти